time you were 20. our series changing
the game profiles extraordin
extraordinary women who are making a
difference now and for future
generations so this morning we're
introducing you to yalitsa jean charles
she's the founder and ceo of healthy
roots dolls the multi-count the
multicultural children's toy company
i'll get it right creates dolls that
help empower girls and teach them to
love their natural hair wish i would
have had these when i was a little girl
the dolls are called curlfriends they
each have textured hair now this is a
cool part it can be washed and styled in
countless ways using real hair care
products what
healthy roots dolls is a finalist for
the doll of the year by the toy
association first on cbs mornings we're
joined by the lovely elisa jean charles
she brought along her very first healthy
roots doll what's the doll's name elisa
zoe zoe and two brand new ones we
welcome you bravo bravo to you so take
us you're in design school where were
you going to school i went to the rhode
island school of design okay so you're
how old are you at the time i was about
20 years old and you had an assignment
what was the assignment so i had to take
rapunzel and redesign her so we had to
take a fairy tale character and put our
own twist on it
so i decided to make her a little brown
girl with kinky curly beautiful hair how
did you go from that class project to
this company now well i'd always had a
passion for social issues especially as
a black woman in america and the
experiences that i had so i went on
facebook and actually started a
conversation after classmates said your
project looks like a doll i was like
okay let me talk to some other people
about the dolls that we played with and
realizing we didn't have dolls that
looked like us growing up and especially
that didn't have the hair that we have
no i can remember when i got my first
black dial long long long time ago and i
remember saying to my mother oh she's
not pretty i don't want that one i want
the blonde one with the long ponytail
yeah can you imagine if we had had dolls
like that
adults like like zoey growing up was
that some of your thinking too i
actually had a similar experience where
my parents wanted to give me a brown
skin doll and i was like that's not the
one from tv yeah the pretty one yes
that's a pretty one exactly and i think
if i had had dolls that look like this
it wouldn't have taken me until i was 20
years old to actually learn how to love
my hair yeah and even if that doll
existed most dolls that i've ever come
in contact with and i have four kids
here
you can't put anything in the doll's
hair you can maybe comb it but even then
it's sort of like careful yeah is this
real hair very different though so her
hair is full of curl power it's a
special fiber design so that you can
actually wash and style it
so that seems like an innovation to me
like did you test a lot of different
types of hair or or to make this happen
so my office is full of dolls we've got
a lot of scalps like lots of doll heads
lots of different scopes designs because
we had to get to the right combination
of product so i designed this from
scratch did the drawings of the face
myself got the samples worked with the
factory and our team has helped us get
it this far now your parents are here
with you today it was lovely meeting
them were they on board when you first
said that you wanted to do something
like this was this a dream they had for
you they definitely wanted me to go be a
doctor but once i got into the school
that i got into they're like alright
we'll let you do your thing and they
always taught me to put my best into
whatever it is that i do so of course i
was gonna make sure that i come out of
art and design school with something
really amazing and these dolls are sold
where so you can find them at target
macy's camp stores and our own website
healthy food stalls and what's been the
reaction from the i can only imagine
react that's a dumb question i can only
imagine what the reaction is so we've
had a lot of different reactions over
the couple of years and we get videos
and we're often times the first thing
girl says she looks just like me yeah
and that's the best experience the kids
screaming when they're getting the box
and actually we get a lot of reactions
from parents and older grandmas and
aunties that say i wish i had had this
growing up but she's so beautiful she
looks like me when i was little and
that's the best thing that we could have
asked for
nominated now tony for doll of the year
what does that mean that's a big deal i
would vote for you if i had to vote but
guys well you can't vote it's a toy
awards public public the public does get
to vote oh so i can vote for you
absolutely please do um it means a lot
to us especially because the new
characters were just launched and it was
an idea seven which one is a new
character so we have marisol marisol and
then guyana guyana so those are new
characters and seeing all three of them
the girlfriends being nominated means a
lot because they're brand new they've
been an idea since i was in college
seven years ago and they're getting
great recognition already
bravo bravo i love that you can put the
products in the hair i think that is
it's amazing it is amazing
jean charles thank you very much for
being here thank you for having me